les discussions ont duré deux heures une
réunion virtuelle en raison de la
pandémie de kovy 19
objectif préserver l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien et des mines et les
tensions à la lumière des défis actuels
les participants ont discuté des travaux
en cours pour préserver l'accord
dissiper est et de la manière d'en
assurer la mise en oeuvre complète et
efficace par l'ensemble des parties un
accord conclu en 2015 à vienne en
autriche mais mise à mal depuis le
retrait américain en mai 2018 et le
rétablissement des sanctions économiques
par les états unis
un dossier iranien qui connaît depuis
fin novembre de nouveaux soubresauts
après l'assassinât d'un éminent
physicien nucléaire dans la foulée
téhéran avait décidé d'installer trois
nouvelles cascades de centrifugeuses
avancé d'enrichissement d'uranium
provoquant une profonde préoccupation de
la france du royaume uni de l'allemagne
pour téhéran
il n'est pas question de payer le prix
fort d'un respect de l'accord sans
obtenir en échange des avantages
économiques promis mais pour cette
question centrale
il faudra attendre l'arrivée de joe
biden à la maison blanche le 20 janvier
prochain
lui qui a confirmé sa volonté de revenir
dans le giron de l'accord de vienne le
président iranien hassan rohani
multiplient d'ailleurs les signaux
d'ouverture à l'attention de la
prochaine administration américaine et
se dit surtout très heureux du départ de
donald trump
certains disent vous êtes surexcités par
rapport à monsieur baden non nous ne le
sommes pas mais nous sommes très heureux
de voir trump partir un certain
enthousiasme tempéré par l'ayatollah ali
khamenei
ce mercredi le guide suprême iranien
déclaré devant des responsables que je
cite les inimitiés avec l'amérique ne
cesseront pas au départ de donald trump